[Music]
it's the unmistakable sound of royalty
handles Masterpiece has played at every
coronation for nearly 300 years
[Music]
[Applause]
this year will preserve such tradition
but also add touches of the new
music will be written by composers
including the likes of Andrew Lloyd
Webber and Debbie Wiseman all personally
chosen by the king himself
Williams and there's Elgar there's
Hubert Parry
um and there's handle and there's also
12 brand new commissions which nobody
will have heard before from 12 composers
that are so different not one of them is
the same and it's going to be an
absolute treat
performing here at Westminster Abbey the
site of coronations for nearly a
thousand years will be musicians from
across the country and indeed the world
choirs from Belfast to Cornwall soloists
from South Africa and even on request of
the king himself Greek Orthodox music in
tribute to his father the late Duke of
Edinburgh
[Music]
also featuring will be the official
Royal harpist a position reinstated by
King Charles when he was Prince of Wales
the role itself was only brought back in
the year 2000 for Captain Finch and I'm
only the sixth person to have been in
this role so obviously we haven't had
any coronations since 2000 so
um yeah it's quite exciting and like I
said it's it's truly an honor to be a
part of such a momentous occasion for
the whole country
altogether it represents a deliberate
blend of the old and the new fit for the
king of an ancient monarchy ruling in
the modern world Matthew Thompson Sky
News